welcome everybody today i'd like to talk
about the portuguese gambit which is
definitely a crazy gambit one of the
craziest gambits that i know of in all
of chess so it's definitely one you want
to be aware of and you especially don't
want to be seeing this game it for the
first time if you're playing
against it
we're gonna go over what it is how to
refute it and then at the end i'm gonna
show a game where i played against the
portuguese gambit so let's not waste any
more time let's get started right away
the portuguese gamut comes out of the
modern scandinavian so it starts with e4
d5 the scandinavian defense e takes d5
and now not queen takes d5 but instead
knight to f6 this is the modern
scandinavian defense and white has a lot
of different options they can do here
for their third move any of these blue
moves here are playable but i personally
think the best move is just d4 just
grabbing more center space trying to
control the center as best as possible
and simply giving back this pawn here on
d5 the main line continues knight takes
d5 and now we can play c4 kick this
knight away there is this trap line
where black plays knight b4 and it looks
like white can win a piece with queen to
a4 but this is actually a really tricky
opening trap and white actually can't
win a piece here it's a really deep and
super tricky line we might go over it on
a later day but just know that queen a4
is no good you don't actually win a
piece just play a3 and you're actually
going to have a really big advantage
with white after a3 stockfish already
gives plus one in this position right
but if black doesn't play knight b4
they'll just play knight b6 you'll play
a middle game white has a really nice
center and you'll continue the game from
here before we look at the portuguese
gamut i just want to go over this move
in this position for white which is c4
and personally i don't think this is a
very good move because black's gonna
play either c6 or e6 and you're gonna
have to take if you don't wanna lose the
pawn anyway and now you have this really
massive hole on d4 which is going to be
a huge weakness in your position as
white
and black already has some really nice
development so personally i wouldn't go
into this there are some people who have
tried it but you can see already here
the win rate for black is really good
just in the lead chess database so
personally i wouldn't go into this and
if you are going to go into this then
you should really make sure that you
know what you're doing all right let's
take a look at the portuguese gamut now
in this position i would recommend to
play d4 and we saw that the main line
continues knight takes d5 but the
portuguese gambit actually starts with
bishop g4 and first this just looks like
a really bad move because it looks like
white is going to be able to play f3 and
then once the bishop moves they can play
c4 and white's going to have this really
massive center and they're going to be
up a pawn they're going to be able to
maintain the massive center and have a
really good game so it just looks like a
terrible blunder at first but let's see
what happens if white does try to go for
this so white will play f3 black plays
bishop f5 and now we go for c4 and here
black is actually going to play e6 so
sacrificing another pawn and you might
think okay after d takes e6 you might
think
the bishop is gonna capture or you know
whatever but
here black actually sacrifices another
pawn
with knight c6
and it just it looks so crazy
for black because black has sacrificed
three pawns now three center pawns and
they're giving up castling rights
and it looks like white is gonna be
totally fine because they're gonna be
able to castle in only three movies like
white has a massive center
which is going to help mitigate the
attack and they're going to be able to
castle in only three moves bishop d3 92
and they're blocking the e file and then
castles and it looks like white is going
to be super safe so the first time you
see this gambit it just looks absolutely
insane which is one of the reasons why
it's so dangerous
the first time i saw this gambit i
actually fell into it and i thought my
opponent was super crazy and i proceeded
to get demolished in only a couple more
moves so of course the most natural move
is e takes f7 and simply king takes f7
and now white's going to try to castle
as quickly as possible so of course
they're going to play bishop d3 but here
it's very easy to forget that black can
actually bring two more pieces into the
attack
with check starting with bishop b4 check
and after knight to c3 now rook to e8
check
and after knight to e2 picking up this
pawn on d4 pressuring the e file and
here of white castles
to try to relieve the pressure they're
just going to lose straight away bishop
takes d3 queen takes d3 and now knight
takes e2 check white is losing the queen
another example line would be hey
white sees that if they castle they lose
to bishop takes d3 so let's take the
bishop first bishop takes f5 well now
black plays knight takes e2 anyway we
can't really recapture this so let's
trade queens first and now we can play
king f2 get out of any discovered
attacks but unfortunately black does
have the option to win a pawn here on c3
they'll be up a pawn but even better for
black is bishop c5 check and after king
to f1 they win a whole piece knight
takes c3 there's no time to recapture
because rook d1 is actually a checkmate
thread so white is completely lost here
one other move that has been tried in
this position is pawn to d5 so just
trying to keep your d-pawn solid expand
in the center and hit black's knight
well black is going to continue here
with knight to b4 so threading a fork we
must defend against this knight to a3
and unfortunately here now black can
play bishop c5 and black's rook is
coming to the e file and white is never
going to be able to castle you can
really see the power of black's pieces
and it doesn't really matter that their
king is on f7 because white has no
pieces to attack the king an example
continuation could go bishop e2 rook to
e8 and king to f1 and you can already
see here in the database that black's
win rate is very very high in these
positions so it's a very pleasant
position for black even though white is
up two pawns so that's really what black
is going for when they play the
portuguese gambit so what's the best way
to deal with the portuguese game well
there's two ways the first way i like to
call the safe refutation because it's
not actually the best way to play
against the gambit but it defuses the
position it gets to an equal middle game
where you're not going to fall into any
of black's opening traps and it's very
simple very easy simply after e4 d5 e
takes d5 knight to f6 you continue with
d4 and now if black plays bishop to g4
we simply play bishop to e2 bishop takes
e2 is forced otherwise white is going to
be up upon with c4 here you can actually
take with either piece queen takes e2 is
the very slight preference among masters
and stockfish so i've put that as the
main line here and after knight to f3
you go into this equal middle game with
equal material and definitely chances
for both sides but you're definitely not
going to fall into any opening traps in
this game and that's it that's the safe
refutation if you don't want to worry
about anything if you don't want to play
a shark game you can decide to play this
and you'll have a good time the second
way to refute the portuguese to gambit
it's a little bit more accurate but it's
definitely going to be much sharper as
well so if you like really sharp or
tactical games or if you just want to
risk having a bigger advantage then this
is definitely the way that you want to
play it and this is what i play as well
we have our line the portuguese gambit
e4 d5 e takes d5 knight to f6 d4 and
bishop g4 and at first it's almost gonna
look like we are gonna go into the
portuguese game but we're gonna start
with f3 black's gonna play bishop to f5
but instead of playing c4 here we're
actually going to play pawn to g4 black
will back their bishop up to g6 and here
we are going to hold on to our pawn with
c4 now you have to be really careful
here because black is going to continue
with either e6 or c6 and you cannot
you cannot take either of those pawns
because if you do
you're basically giving black exactly
what they want you're going to get into
a position very similar to the main line
and it's going to be very unpleasant so
just this as an example if black plays
e6 and if you do take this pawn simply
knight c6 e takes f7 and king takes f7
and we can see this is a very very
similar position to the main line which
we looked at which was not good for
white at all and you can see the win
rates in the leachup database
correlate with that black is winning
most of the time so after black plays
either e6 or c6 you don't want to take
that you're simply going to defend your
pawn again with knight c3 and it looks
like kind of a bad move at first because
it looks like you're just giving
yourself these
super weak double isolated pawns by
allowing black to take but after black
takes with e takes d5 we're actually not
going to take back straight away we're
going to play
g5 and now
everything totally makes sense because
this knight is kicked away and we're
gonna be able to recapture the pawn on
d5 and not have double isolated pawns
and we'll be up a pawn so it's going to
be fantastic black has chosen two spots
to try to move this knight let's first
take a look at knight to h5 now it'll be
very tempting to capture this pawn
because you have a fantastic knight a
fantastic center but here white can
actually just completely win a piece
with pont f4 and the threat is bishop to
e2
and the knight is trapped and there's
actually no way
to stop
this threat well actually one way to
stop this threat would be to play h6 and
then if you play bishop to e2 black
could defend with h takes g5 but bishop
to e2 isn't the only threat in the
position for example if black tries h6
we could simply play f5 and this is
deflection from the bishop we're gonna
pick up the knight anyway so we actually
have two pretty big threats in the
position which are f5 and bishop to e2
and black cannot stop both of them so
let's say that black captures this pawn
on c4 we're gonna play bishop to e2 and
queen to e7 is no problem we simply play
king to f1 what is actually gonna be up
a full piece here and stockfish
evaluates this position as plus 1.8 for
white it's not super simple because
white is definitely going to have some
long-term king safety problems but being
up a piece it should still definitely be
winning for white the other choice for
black in this position is knight f to d7
and this is definitely much less
ambitious for black we're simply going
to play knight takes d5 knight c6 bishop
f4 bishop d6 is gonna be forced bishop
takes d6 c takes d6 and h4 to defend the
g5 pawn white is simply going to be up a
pawn here black has this big weakness on
d6 white has a massive center really the
only thing that white
doesn't have is they're going to have
once again long-term king safety
problems but the extra material and
extra space should be enough to offset
this although once again this is going
to be a pretty sharp game so if this is
not your style then you might want to
consider playing the safe refutation
instead and that's it that's really all
you need to know about this really crazy
at the portuguese gambit i actually
played a game
where my opponent played the portuguese
gambit i played it last night on stream
and it actually inspired me to refresh
my knowledge and review the theory on
the portuguese gamut you can see in the
game i actually forgot the theory a
little bit so without so without further
ado you guys can take a look at that
game enjoy
we've got at least there's five minutes
left until the next game
okay
that means we have time for a 3-0 game i
haven't played a blitz game in
a while
a long time
so we
very well might
lose this but good luck
good luck to dabo five thousand we've
got the
this is the portuguese gambit
you're not gonna fool me with a
portuguese gambit dude
can't get me yo
e6 knight c3
um
takes
h4 or g5
is it g5
not getting me with the portuguese game
i was actually i was actually planning
on making a video about this gambit
um
yeah
g5
knight d7 or knight h5 also works
um i think we're supposed to take here
yeah and i think this position is like
plus one for white
it's obviously still very tricky though
do you win a piece
i think
you actually you maybe win a piece in
this line
um i can't remember
we're up a pawn which is
not bad
check
got this thank you
thank you thank you
whoa
oh my goodness
check
we've got the on passant move if he
plays it he allows us to play it yeah
that that doesn't seem like a very
good
move
to me
doesn't seem like a very good move
oh my goodness
move faster
okay
should be
good
maybe
king d7 i feel like was
very likely a
bad move
wow
wow
ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
zero
oh no my time i have no time left
how did i end up down a piece
this is so sad
[Music]
oh no my pawn
oh my goodness
oh my gosh
your game started thank you for telling
me
i realized we lost we not only we lost
the blitz game we also lost
the rapid game by forfeit